i mean
let's take a moment and you just
performed at the oscars right for the
first time ever i mean how are you
feeling i feel really excited i feel
like i'm still on edge like i was so
nervous before i went out and it was the
first female rap performance at the
grant at the grammys at the oscars ever
how does that feel to have that title it
feels like yeah i did that now what
okay i just talked to john leguizamo he
was raving about your performance he's
like she they should have had her do the
rap in the song not me
well thank you
were you nervous at all i was a little
nervous before i went out there because
i've never been to the oscars before so
i was like i just want to be great
talk about the dress
stunning thank you i feel like pink
might be my color i don't know
what's the secret about the outfit we
ask everyone um i mean they cut the hips
out and i don't really have hips
so the secret is that you know just got
to be making a stallion or
pull it off
you were in the room we're asking
everyone how did the will chris moment
feel i wasn't in the room i had just got
off stage and then i saw it on twitter
and i was like well damn
what do you feel like
what's your reaction and where should
they go from here
they should go home
i should go home and think about it
it was crazy though
shout out to will
did you watch a speech at all no i just
came here straight after yeah i just saw
everything on the internet with
everybody else is this your first vanity
fair party
this is my first vanity fair after party
okay i feel pretty important
you know
i mean we're like we of course we love
watching everything you do and watching
your rise and tonight is a big night
like you've accomplished so much but how
did it kind of feel to be like i am
making history tonight i just crushed it
and this is a real moment i just feel
good and i feel happy to be here and
that's all i gotta say i'll let you go
but what's next for you what can the
fans expect my album
[Music]